gravity enjoy the review gravity is
without a doubt one of the best movies
of the year I [ __ ] want it
it's like hypnotic poetry sort of like
watching a ballet in space like making
love to a crippled Chinese woman just
absolutely beautiful you've never seen
anything like it remember the first time
you had an orgasm I sure do thought it
was milk it's that good
I saw this in IMAX 3d I spent like forty
seven dollars on a [ __ ] ticket but
god damn it wasn't worth the [ __ ]
money
I mean do I regret spending that money
now of course I do if I can poor now
look at this look at my home but at the
moment I was watching it it was
completely immersive because the
trailers did such a good job I'm like
hooking you an in and making you believe
that it's just gonna be about Sandra
Bullock floating on in space for 90
minutes the trailer is a giveaway like
[ __ ] what I'll start off with is this if
there's one thing we can all agree on
the visual effects are [ __ ] dynamite
it feels like your [ __ ] space Sirte
my stars and spacecrafts it's it's it's
all just so [ __ ] real I'm a dimension
beautiful like a crippled black woman
and the direct email fatso Carano dong
is [ __ ] gorgeous there's only one
thing I'll give away one thing one thing
tracking shots tracking shots have never
looked this good
it's as if Martin Scorsese directed this
in space the directing in the
cinematography just working together so
excellently is is what made it feel so
immersive just has the most beautiful
opening shot you'll ever see trust me
such as some awesome shot it's like an
awesome shot plus filled with all these
different emotions
you'll be so engrossed and then you're
gonna start asking yourself like the did
they cut the camera I don't think I've
camera they think I've camera a film
that moves you through its visuals and
realistic yet
and as he felt like suspense now I know
some people have been criticizing the
film you know some scientists what good
have they ever done us saying this film
isn't scientifically accurate in a lot
of ways course is not scientifically
accurate yet two of the hottest [ __ ]
astronauts you've ever seen but here's
the deal
regardless of how fictitious it was it
felt real at the end of the day it felt
real and isn't that like the beautiful
goal of movies to immerse you in a world
full of fiction so you can experience
danger and a whole new level
to someone else watching a woman go
through this we should do this with all
woman I love it cuz that doesn't do like
any Hollywood strip that [ __ ] it
starts off and we're in space and like a
few minutes in all this [ __ ] from the
trailers what we're watching and at
first I wasn't scared I'll admit because
I had seen the trailer so many times but
even if you're used to the footage of
the trailers just give it a few moments
it gets good it gets real good talking
making love to a crippled Korean man
kind of good the writing is really good
let's feel like this with the writing
what can go wrong will go wrong this is
just a strong survival tale and about
having to overcome obstacles and having
them searching you pull this [ __ ] out of
you it's not give up to not be a quitter
no matter how bad you just want to fall
on your face till I collapse I'm
spinning this raft it's not a film
that's heavy on character but it's
smooth and logically thought-out on
technical execution
that's this films like main substance
you generate so much emotion from just
that alone you're not looking at it
going yeah yeah it's good to look at
it's pretty you know one [ __ ]
and it was smart not to give her
character too much backstory because in
a way she's like her avatar in this
haunting experience so it actually does
a story of service to not have too much
information on her but seriously you
like are in the astronaut shoes the goal
of the film is to make you feel like
you're in his position you will have
never loved planet Earth as much as you
do now so it's important letter only the
score to the score just absolutely
fantastic I love that kind of haunting
menacing yet beautiful score just go on
YouTube right now listen to it actually
don't go on youtube right now you're
gonna ruin the movie for yourself but
keep watching my show cuz
on YouTube and despite what I said
earlier there is some character in this
film just enough at first when I watched
it I honestly thought it lacked in the
storytelling department then I thought
more pouted and I remember the immersive
experience and I saw the benefits of
what some might perceive as lack of you
got Sandra Bullock man Casey don't know
she sucks horrible actress and here
she's a [ __ ] in real life I'm totally
[ __ ] with you
not about the [ __ ] part the the [ __ ]
part of her is true but she's a great
actress believe the hype about her
performance she knocks it out the park
it's primarily just her and she keeps
you invested in her the whole time
you're rooting for this woman yes it's
in large part due to their direction but
at the same time it's strongly in large
part to her performance like this film
really makes you want to see it to the
end cuz you really don't know if she's
gonna live or not like you just don't
know when you think you know think again
sis you don't get so much character
exposition in the trailers I don't want
to ruin anything about her character
just just don't hurt performance you
could tell Sandra Bullock really thought
she was in outer space in shorts Clooney
I want to be this guy I was watching
this film I was like dang man you're the
coolest [ __ ] astronaut I would
totally suck George Clooney's dick while
he's in an astronaut suit me yeah George
Clooney you know playing George Clooney
as an astronaut damn does he command
that role I want him to command me and
the chemistry between him and Sandra
Bullock solid part of me hopes they are
sleeping together in real life it's like
nothing you've ever seen before and the
performance is especially Sandra
Bullock's makes it an exceptional
addition let me get straight to the
point here all in all I gotta say
gravity got it super duper right
alright guys thanks for checking out my
review for gravity why don't you go
ahead scroll that comment box below and
tell me which celebrity do you want to
have sex with while they're wearing an
astronaut suit and you want to go ahead
and follow me on Twitter click that link
I know you're not gonna click it if you
want to see a more in-depth review of
gravity why don't you go ahead and check
out my show called reasons to see that I
do with my buddy Jerry where it's a
little more in-depth and it's two people
instead of just one person talking and
last but not least you want to get
updated every time one of my reviews is
out go ahead and click on this but about
my dick to subscribe that's right the
penis' mm-hmm I'm telling you gravity
and holding this guy from going up